-Our first guest is
a very talented actress
who stars in the new movie
"The Lost Daughter,"
which is in select theaters
Friday
and streaming on Netflix
December 31st.
Please welcome Dakota Johnson!
Ah! Yes, that's what
I'm talking about!
Ah!
I miss you.
It's always great to see you.
-I miss you too.
And this is so sad.
I mean, it's great.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Thank you, yeah.
It's sad.
Yeah, I wish you were here.
But, yeah, you're doing well?
-I'm good. Yeah.
-Good.
-I'm good.
How are you doing?
-I'm doing good.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so much bigger than you.
I can see what I look like
next to you.
-No, I like this size of you.
-And it's so weird.
-We always want more of you,
so now we just made you actually
physically bigger now.
Yeah, we love it.
More Dakota Johnson the better,
that's what I say.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Have to talk about this 'cause
the last time you were
on the show,
you were very funny.
We were talking about
this article you did for
or a photo shoot spread you did
for "Architectural Digest"
or something of your home.
And there was a bowl of limes
in the kitchen.
Some people know
what I'm talking about.
[ Laughter ]
In the article you said like,
"Oh, yeah, I love limes"
or something like that.
And then you came on our show.
You said actually
you don't love them.
You said you're allergic
to limes.
And it caused
a giant controversy.
I mean, this is the --
This could have been
the end of your career.
There was -- People wrote
articles. Look at this.
"Dakota Johnson lied to us
about loving limes."
[ Laughter ]
And this is major headlines.
This is --
"Dakota Johnson
selling her house
and confessing she hates limes
is the biggest plot twist
of 2021."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Feels like there was way more
important news than that.
-Are you aware of the fallout?
I mean, how are you dealing with
this crisis?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's been really hard,
Jimmy.
-[ Laughs ]
Do you not like limes?
-I don't really care
about limes.
I love them and I also found out
after I did "Arch Digest."
I did that, and, you know,
they have somebody
who is super talented
come in and make your house
look amazing.
So they put this
big bowl of limes,
which I saw
while we were filming.
And it was funny.
So I talked about it because
who has a bowl of only limes?
Apparently me.
-Apparently you.
-And then I did an allergy test
a few weeks later,
and it turns out
that I'm allergic to limes.
But I never knew because usually
when I have them they're
in, like, a tequila.
[ Laughter ]
So...
-Yeah. That's kind of -- Yeah.
Is there anything else you're
allergic to so we can get it out
of the way now so there's
no more controversy?
-Yes.
Thank you so much for asking.
I'm so excited to have this
be in the news too.
I'm allergic to soy.
-There you go.
[ Audience murmurs ]
Wow. Yeah, there you go.
There you go, the reaction.
-Don't send me any edamame
this Christmas season.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, we're not going to get you
any edamame.
What are you doing
for the holidays?
Do you have any plans?
-I'm going to be at home
with my family.
Some of my family
is coming to my house.
-Oh, that -- So you're hosting
the whole family?
Is that stressful?
-I haven't really thought
about it.
[ Laughter ]
It's fast approaching, isn't it?
-Yeah, it's like next week,
yeah.
You really have to -- Yeah.
You have to plan something.
-No, I don't.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to get, like, food.
You have to do something.
You have to entertain.
What are you --
You gonna play games?
Do you play board games?
-Yeah. Well, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Games for sure.
We'll do, like, Scrabble
and all the, you know,
the games.
But, like, I feel like it's
better and more relaxing
for everybody if they just
fend for themselves.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, what?
Wait, so your parents
come and you go,
"Yeah, look, if you're hungry,
you're an adult.
Get something."
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly. They're all grown-ups.
-What's your go-to
Scrabble word? Do you have one?
I have a great one for you.
-Does anyone have a go-to
Scrabble word?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, I definitely have mine.
-That's impossible.
-No. I'll tell it to you
and it'll be yours.
-What is it?
-"Za."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, like short for pizza?
-Yeah.
Pizza's too long of a word.
-Some za?
-Pizza's too long of a word
for me to say.
So I call it Za.
-[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
It's in the Scrabble dictionary.
"Za" is a real word.
-It is, it is.
-Changes the whole game.
-Isn't -- So is J-A?
-J-O.
-Q-A.
-Q-A?
-Mm-hmm.
-I'm going to challenge you
on that one.
-I'm really good at Scrabble.
-We'll play next time
you come on.
Are you going to watch
any holiday movies?
-I really love --
Okay, my whole life --
Well, no, not my whole life.
That's intense.
But when I was little, I went
through a phase where I watched
"Home Alone"
every day of the year.
[ Laughter ]
-Every single day you watched
"Home Alone"?
-Every day.
-Wow.
-I was really into it.
-I was like that with
"Pee-wee's Big Adventure."
[ Laughter ]
I watched it every single day.
Memorized every line.
Used to do impersonations of
everybody.
I loved it so much, I mean --
-Yeah.
-If I quizzed you on
"Home Alone,"
do you think you'd do well?
-I think maybe -- I don't know.
Maybe. Let's try.
Do you have a question?
-I have some questions. I do.
-Oh [bleep], okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Can you say that --
-Sorry.
-Can you say that on TV?
No, you can't.
-Oh, shoot!
-Thank you.
-Is what I meant.
-Alright, ready for this?
-Yeah.
-What are the burglars'
first names?
-Harry and Marv.
-Wow! That is correct!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, I thought that was
a hard one.
-That's simple.
-That's an easy one for you?
-Okay. Come on.
-Alright.
What do the burglars
refer to themselves as
in the first "Home Alone" movie?
What do they call themselves?
-"The Wet Bandits."
-Wow, that's completely correct.
-Because they --
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They leave the bathtubs
running.
They leave the water
running in the houses.
-Wow, that's right.
-That's their calling card.
-Wow! This is -- This is
fantastic that you know so much.
Alright, how about --
This is a tough one.
What is the name of the movie
that Kevin watches
while eating ice cream?
-It's not a real movie.
It's, um...
It's a fake movie.
It's called...
"Angels" something.
Oh, sh--
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-"Dirty Angels"?
"Dirty, Dirty Angels"?
-No.
"Dirty, Dirty Angels,"
but very close.
"Angels with Filthy Souls."
-Oh, same thing.
[ Laughs ]
[ Ding! ]
-We gave you credit for that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
We gave you credit for it.
The judges like you here.
Okay, what character does
Macaulay Culkin's brother
Kieran Culkin play?
-Fuller because --
And he wets the bed.
[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
-Is that right?
-That is correct.
[ Ding! ]
Fuller. That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
-Can I tell you something
quickly just like as a --
just, like, an intermission
from the game?
-Yeah.
-I saw Macaulay Culkin recently.
And I've never seen him
in real life,
but I saw him because he was
walking in the Gucci show.
-Was he really?
-And I was sho-ck-ed.
[ Laughter ]
-You made that word
three syllables.
[ Laughter ]
Sho-ck-ed?
Wow. Because you're such a fan?
-Well, logically, like, I know
that he's grown up, you know.
But then when you see him,
he's a man.
[ Laughter ]
And he was a man
wearing Gucci clothes,
just walking down
Hollywood Boulevard.
-Yeah. He is a man, yeah.
It's unbelievable.
[ Laughter ]
Can we talk about
your new movie?
-Oh, we're not going to finish
the game?
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I was going to win?
-I feel like it's too easy.
You're getting all of them
right.
I mean, you're clearly a fan.
I'll ask you one last one.
Ready?
What gift does the fake
Santa Claus give Kevin?
-Oh, Tic Tacs.
-Wow!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is unbelievable!
You're a fan!
You're amazing! You really are
a fan. I love that.
Next time you come on,
you can ask me questions
about "Pee-wee's Big Adventure."
-Okay.
-I want to talk about your new
movie, "The Lost Daughter."
Congrats, by the way.
Today it got two Golden Globe
nominations.
So that's always good to get.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Two Critics Choice Award noms.
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
This is --
-Nom, nom, nom.
-Yeah. Nom, nom, nom.
Tell everyone what it's about.
Can you explain the movie?
-"The Lost Daughter" is a movie
based on the book
by Elena Ferrante.
And it is about a woman who is
vacationing on a beach.
And she becomes sort of obsessed
with this young mother
and her daughter,
who seem to be having
a troubling time.
The young woman is
kind of struggling with
difficult things in her life.
-Yeah.
-And I play that person.
Her name is Nina.
And it's with Olivia Colman
and Jessie Buckley
and loads of other
supremely talented people.
And Maggie Gyllenhaal
directed it.
And it is pretty intense.
-Yeah. Congrats on being in
such an awesome film.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Well deserved, buddy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dakota Johnson
in "The Lost Daughter."
Take a look at this.
-So she's not calming down.
[ Child crying ]
-Yeah.
-Mommy!
-It's been a weird day.
We found her and then she lost
her doll.
-I used to have a doll
like that.
Called Mina.
-Nina?
-Mina.
Or Mini Mama
as my mother called her.
You'll find it.
-Yeah.
[ Crying continues ]
-See you tomorrow.
-Dakota Johnson, everybody!
"The Lost Daughter" is
in select theaters Friday
and streaming on Netflix
December 31st.